This notion of variables having different
values and different contexts
is sometimes called scope.
There's some sort of global scope that
we start in where we're assigning values to variables,
but then inside myfun,
there's a new x that has a new value,
and what this means is that our environment
cannot be a flat mapping.
We had hoped before that we'd be able to use
a single Python dictionary,
but this myfun example shows that that's
really not going to cut it because in a single dictionary,
you can only have x bind to 1 thing,
and we need to know that x is sometimes
outside x and sometimes os lasiandras.
Let's get some practice with these concepts with another quiz.
This one explicitly on scoping,
and we'll do it together in the interpreter.
So we have x gets outside x and
y gets outside y just like before.
So I've written out this program,
and it's a little more complicated than last time.
It has 2 functions, funone and funtwo,
my phenomenal cosmic naming scheme,
with a few printouts.
X starts out as outside x.
Y starts out as outside y.
When we enter function 1,
we print out current value of x in scope,
the current value of y in scope, and then we call function 2.
Function 2 also prints out its value of x and its value of y,
and down here we get the ball rolling by calling
function 1 on Hong Kong in 1997.
So the quiz for you is to fill in these blanks,
the 3 formal parameter declarations,
2 for funone and 1 for funtwo,
but you can only use x, y, and z.
So for each one of these blanks, fill it in with
either x or y or z, and that's it.
In order to make the output of this program,
match exactly what we see down here,
funone x Hong Kong, funone y outside y,
funtwo x outside x, funtwo y funone y.
This is a bit of a puzzle, try it out.